Shane Gillis Theo Von Bert Cher and Tom
sagora have all been making rounds on
the same sport show if you've never
heard of Pat McAfee he's an ex NFL
player and current host of the Pat
McAfee show Pat McAfee baby the
goat let me tell you something Pat I'm
here with big Tommy buns what's up man
baby on top of interviewing some of the
biggest names in sports and comedy Pat
McAfee is an incredibly funny person and
has even dabbled in stand up himself it
was like one of the original meds little
block characters could barely run
was like the old school days these kids
today they got these characters that
like jump out of your screen his
natural ability to relate to the
funniest people in the world is probably
why